alors qu'il était ministre de
l'environnement monsieur blanchet
contourner le bac pour trois projets
majeurs soit l'inversion de la ligne 9
bainbridges
la cimenterie mécanismes et le forage
sur l'île d'anticosti
[Musique]
yves françois blanchet était ministre de
l'environnement du québec dans le
gouvernement marois de 2012 à 2014 dans
le dossier de l'oléoduc d'enbridge il
préférait éviter la population et les
experts dans le cadre d'une commission
parlementaire au lieu de tenir un examen
du bureau des audiences publiques en
environnement
pour ce qui est du pétrole d'anticosti
le ministre blanchet proposait une étude
du bape
mais seulement après qu'on ait explorer
et mesurer le potentiel pétrolier de
l'île sur anticosti monsieur blanchet se
défend aujourd'hui en disant qu'ils
suivaient la ligne tracée par son
gouvernement
j'étais dans un gouvernement est dans un
gouvernement on doit jouer en équipe
comme joueur des caps l'ancien ministre
ne s'est pas opposé au projet de
s'immoler kennis à port daniel le
candidat libéral steven guilbeault
dénoncé lui à l'époque l'absence
d'examen du bac dans ce dossier s'il
avait été devant le bac elle aurait pu
éviter beaucoup beaucoup de problèmes au
niveau de l'acceptabilité sociale de son
projet
si l'ancien directeur d'équipé recentra
au bilan de monsieur blanchet cette
dominance l'environnement steven
guilbeault a aussi dit ceci à propos de
la cimenterie on est plutôt d'accord
avec le fait que c'est probable
probablement deux cimenteries qui sera
plus plus efficace plus propre en
quelque sorte la cimenterie mécanisme de
par daniel est le plus gros émetteurs
industriels de gaz à effet de serre au
québec